you're the big one you really love me
[Music]
no one goes all out for valentine's day
like offset and cardi b
oh snappity snap snap the love bird
celebrated cupid's holiday a day early
on sunday and documented the whole thing
on social media buckle your seat belts
because things are about to get
luxurious
really
really luxurious
he did that
he loved me for real
he loved me forever you love me for real
oh my god i'm definitely sure oh my god
i want to show this to my mom i didn't
call my mom
the couple kicked things off by watching
the la rams defeat the cincinnati
bengals in the super bowl in los angeles
and when the big game was over they
headed back to the house for what i like
to call the super bowl of valentine's
day surprises where the migos rapper had
set up a lavish surprise for the grammy
winner i don't know
this so much
this is too much i don't deserve this
yeah we're talking tons and tons and
tons of flowers people
that do that
we're talking rose petals on the floor
rose petals in the pool giant
heart-shaped rose arches rose
arrangements galore and a massive pink
heart made of what else
roses
oh yes honey i'm so happy
i'm so happy
i'm so sad
i'm so happy is that because i don't
know why yeah the 29 year old uprapper
was feeling all the feels
i love him
but it wasn't just candles and roses it
was chanel people
lots and lots of chanel this is so cute
this actually looked good with this
[ __ ]
oh this one matched my outfit too who
got this at
oh my god
oh my god
this is cute
yeah count them that's one two three
four five six chanel bags
another one
another one
oh and let's not forget offset had
dinner ready to go too
yeah real food none of that sushi boys
you know
yeah
look at the glaze on there
the glaze just sitting on that thing
as for cardi she loved it so much she
was happy dancing
and she said we shouldn't be surprised
if they make baby number three
this is why we keep happy kids
i love you
of course offset and cardi share a
three-year-old daughter culture and
welcomed their second child a baby boy
back in september it's a blessing for
god and while the couple have yet to
reveal his name cardi recently tweeted
that she's thinking about having it
inked in a very prominent place quote
random but i'm one percent close to
tatting my son's name on my face i
really really want to do it so she
hasn't done that yet but she did get
matching body art with her man during
the latest episode of her facebook watch
series cardi tries hey guys i'm gonna do
something crazy for valentine's day with
my husband
i'm going to give him a tattoo
let me rephrase cardi and her man inked
each other with their wedding
anniversary 9 20 17.
what's happy whether it's chanel flowers
or tattoos these two know how to do
romance right
[Music]
you